more than 5,700 active-duty troops will
spend Thanksgiving at their new posts
along the us-mexico border President
Trump sent them there to support the
Border Patrol ahead of the arrival of
thousands of immigrants from Central
America CBS News confirms the White
House could expand that mission under a
directive that may allow the troops to
use deadly force new Joe Jang is near
the president's mar-a-lago Resort where
he is spending the holiday we jog good
morning good morning to you Alex
president Trump is eager to keep the
attention on the southern border but
this move is already raising legal
questions a memo from chief of staff
John Kelly obtained by CBS News allows
use of force including lethal force
where necessary crowd control temporary
detention and cursory search those sound
like law enforcement actions but it's
against the law for the US military to
act as a police force Secretary of
Defense James Madison chily called the
memo a request without committing to
authorizing it he said there has not
been any call for lethal force and the
troops will be armed with shields not
guns the soldiers were sent to the
border right before the midterm
elections when President Trump put the
migrant caravan at the center of the GOP
campaign this is all part of a hardline
immigration push by President Trump who
actually suffered a setback this week
when a federal judge ruled against his
proclamation that would prevent migrants
who do not show up at an official port
of entry from seeking asylum Alex we
doctor the president called the judge in
that very case and Obama judge the Chief
Justice of the u.s. John Roberts pushed
back what was the White House reaction
to that this was surprising to all
because it was an extraordinary
statement by Supreme Court Chief Justice
John Roberts who said in part we do not
have Obama judges or Trump judges the
independent judiciary is something we
should all be thankful for it is
incredibly rare for Supreme Court
justices especially Roberts to wade into
the political fray so it is a sign of
how strongly he feels but president
Trump has said reshaping the judiciary
is part of his signature legacy so it's
no
surprised that he is doubling down on
those comments all right we Jerry much